beat Ryan shushil ik a street freestyle
rider from Wisconsin he's attempting to
set a world record for the fastest
wheelie on ice
something best left to a professional
a normal regular wheelie looks difficult
enough let alone doing one on hice Ryan
previously lost the lower part of his
left leg in a motorcycle accident but
still managed to go 108 miles per hour
while balanced on one wheel I don't
think anything's gonna stop him and
that's so cool so is this a normal bike
this guy wanted to beat the world record
so badly that he designed and made his
own wheels to do it it's made of a very
soft rubber it doesn't get as hard and
stiff when he gets on the ice and that
allows it to maintain traction the
second modification that Ryan makes the
de tire is that he screws in these studs
that can grip the ice without his Ryan
get up on one wheel in order for Ryan to
pull off this wheelie he actually has to
work against the design of the
motorcycle the motorcycle is designed to
be stable when Ryan wants to pop a
wheelie what he has to do is open the
throttle full tilt and we does that that
creates a huge torque on the back tire
and the bike has a reactive torque which
lifts up the front tire and that moves
the center of mass above the back wheel
he has to keep perfectly balanced on top
of that bike any shifting to the left or
right could result in disaster yes Ryan
skills are wheely impressive